نزيف الوثائق المسربه مستمر داخل
البينتاغون و واشنطن تعيش حاله استنفار
قصوى لضبط المتلبسين في القضيه دفعه جديده
من الوثائق المسربه من وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تنتشر كنار في الهشيم على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وتهز عرش كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين الامريكيين صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كشفت عن تسريب ما يعادل 100
وثيقه سريه اضافيه تتعلق بالامن القومي
للولايات المتحده الوثائق الخاصه بالجيش
الاوكراني شملت صورا فوتوغرافيه لمخططات
تسليم الاسلحه كما شملت جزءا من الخطط
العسكريه المحتمل اعتمادها في الهجوم
الاوكراني المرتقب ضد القوات الروسيه
التسريبات هذه المره لم تتوقف عند حدود
الحرب الاوكرانيه كما هو الحال في الدفعه
الاولى بل شملت ملفات اخرى تتعلق بقضايا
الشرق الاوسط والملف الصيني والمسرح
العسكري لمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
وملفات الارهاب
دفعه ثانيه اذا خلفت عاصفه من التهم
المتبادله حول المسؤول عن تسريب هذه
الوثائق من خلف ابواب البنتاجون المصاده
باحكام الاكثر من ذلك هو ان المسؤوليه قد
تتحملها وكالات مخابرات اخرى غير
الامريكيه كما هو الحال بالنسبه للمخابرات
الاستراليه
ونيوزيلنديه والكنديه والبريطانيه ايضا
التي تتعاون وتنقل المعلومات فيما بينها
لكن الخبر قد ياخذ ابعاد اخرى غير
المتداوله بشكل رسمي على وسائل الاعلام
فالتدفق المستمر للوثائق المسربات طرح
علامات استفهامين حقيقيه حول صحه
المعلومات فقد يكون الامر متعلقا بحرب
معلومات بين روسيا والمعسكر الغربي طرح لم
تستبعده الكثير من الاطراف داخل موسكو
التي وصفت هذه التسريبات بعمل استخباراتي
غربي من اجل تضليل تقر صحيفه نيويورك
دائما نقلا عن مسؤولين الروس ووسط فوضى
المعلومات هذه يبدو ان الحروب الموازيه
لحرب المدافع ستكون اكثر حسما في هذا
الصراع وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات